[Music]
hello everyone
so uh we'll start our discussion
uh or we'll continue our discussion on
strain
but uh we'll start it off with where we
exactly left in the last time
so we had found out that under the
consideration that del u by del x your
magnitude is much much less than
one we obtained this
so we want to uh use this uh expression
and proceed from here
to again go back to uh if you remember
our original definition of engineering
string and perhaps obtain some useful
expression for it
under these new considerations so we'll
start from this expression
okay so what we have on the left hand
side
is as before del small x vector
magnitude square
is equal to the capital x vector
magnitude square
plus twice d x i
d x j both capital x and
epsilon 9 j the small or the infinite
symbol strain tensor
now what we want to do is we want to
introduce the unit vectors corresponding
to these
uh to this dxi and the dxj so we
understand
that this dxi
it is a vector and it has a certain
magnitude
which we again understand to be nothing
but this itself the dx vector magnitude
without the square now if we want to
represent
this general vector in terms of its
magnitude
then we should also be able to isolate
out the
the unit vector which represents its
direction so what i mean is that
so let's go to the rough column and
discuss it very simply
so back in your high school or maybe
first year so when you wrote a vector
like this
so you could
write it like this the same vector
magnitude but some kind
of a unit vector
which is along the direction of the a
vector
so you see this unit vector it captures
the direction of this vector
and this magnitude it captures of course
the magnitude of this vector
so this is the same idea that we're
going to utilize here
so d x
i or equivalently d x
j that will be equal to
d x vector magnitude because this is
nothing but the
dx vector itself and that should be
equal to
the unit vector along the dxi
so
ni
[Music]
is the
unit vector
[Music]
alone dxi
[Music]
okay
similarly we have for dxj
d capital x vector magnitude
n j where again
n j is the unit vector
[Music]
along the x j so if we
use these n i's and n j's so what we
have
dx vector magnitude square is equal to
the same thing as before
the capital x vector magnitude square
plus
we obtain a dx vector magnitude from
here
and another dx vector magnitude square
from magnitude from there
so overall we have dx vector
magnitude square and then
an i n j
[Music]
epsilon i j so exactly the same thing as
before
but re-represent it in terms of the unit
vectors
now note that
this particular combination ninj epsilon
ij
as before it has no free indices
so earlier we had this particular
combination here also we had no free
indices
here also we have no free indices so
both the i and j are repeated and
this particular combination is a scalar
combination
but is it perhaps possible to express
this particular combination
in uh in a compact or a vector notation
so the answer of course is yes we can
always find an equivalent
representation and that is
n i n j
epsilon i j that is
equivalent to
n unit vector transpose
dotted with
epsilon dotted with
n unit vector so
if it is not very clear to you how
this is coming out you can
perhaps
rethink about this in terms
of components like this
so n1
n2 n3
so what i'm doing is i'm rewriting this
or re-representing this
in terms of the matrix notation
so this is equivalent to
so
you see this entire thing written in
very compact notation
is rewritten in the matrix form in this
kind of a
in this kind of form and please note
that this is not something
new to you back when you were studying i
believe
uh your mathematics two in your second
semester of first year
uh you came across something uh called
the quadratic form uh in the linear
in one of the linear algebra chapters or
in one of the matrix chapters
so this is exactly that this is again
nothing but the
quadratic form and please note that the
quadratic form here
is very much a scalar quantity okay so
what is the use of all this
well you see we can rewrite that earlier
expression
so what we are going to do here is we
are going to take this dx vector
magnitude square is common
so that will simplify our expression a
little bit
we're going to take this as common we
will be left with
1 plus 2 now we are going to write this
down
this is the more compact notation
okay now uh some of you
uh who are of a more practical bent of
mind and
do not want to be bothered with this
much
of maths and theory you may be wondering
what is the point of
of writing this once in terms of index
notation in an app
then again in this compact notation and
begin in getting this
matrix notation well you see
we are writing this as it is convenient
to us
for various purposes so it is a very
very purposeful
kind of way of approaching the subject
so when we are writing this down either
on a piece of paper
here i am writing on a digital board
we are basically manipulating algebraic
symbols and there it is
a little bit easier to deal with this
index notation
uh but ultimately when you have to solve
problems
uh not just for the purpose of your
examination
uh but in a more professional
environment whether it is
or engineering research or actual
uh professional engineering field uh
you'll see that you know always have to
ultimately resort to computers
and when you're dealing with computers
you ultimately have to
make the computer understand things in
terms of matrices
uh well usually so
uh so that's that's the purpose here as
far as the algebraic manipulations are
concerned
we want to do the algebra in as simple
as form as possible writing as
uh as few symbols as possible by taking
the help of the index notation
and then we also want to re re represent
the thing
in terms of matrix matrices so that
later on when we have to make the
computer understand
then we can easily feed the values as
desired in this particular form okay
now uh as i had told you earlier
the motivation of proceeding in this
line
is to ultimately obtain a simplified
expression for the engineering stream so
remember we had started this
uh this entire section on string by
defining the engineering string so
how can we go back to that so let's take
a quick look at the
engineering string if you go back a
few slides you see here
we have the definition of the
engineering strain here you see
it is very much involving the dx small
uh
the small x vector in the d capital x
vector but in a slightly different
fashion
and because we want we wanted to avoid
the use of square roots
we had taken this squares and that is
why we are still stuck with this square
roots
with the squares but we want to get rid
of it
and you'll see that see in the next
slide
how how we can do that so from we are
i'm going to carry over this expression
to the next
uh thing all that i'm going to do is i'm
going to divide throughout by d
capital expected magnitude square so
this thing i am going to divide here
[Music]
so
this is equal to you can see this is
just
one plus
two in unit vector transpose
dotted with the strain tensor
dotted with again the
[Music]
in unit vector now
if we go back to the definition of
the engineering string
so we want to utilize this
expression but we know that the
engineering strain
is equal to this
which implies that
the small x vector magnitude divided by
the capital expected magnitude
is nothing but 1 plus
epsilon e okay so if that is true
then this is nothing but the square of
this
which means
that we simply have this thing to be
true
1 plus epsilon e
the engineering strain whole square is
equal to
1 plus twice n vector transpose
in unit vector now we are almost
done with this derivation we just have
to
uh employ one more trick so you see
we can expand this very easily like this
[Music]
pretty simple
[Music]
but overall we are considering
very small deformations
overall
we are working under this assumption
that this is small
so small deformations
[Music]
now if this deformations overall the
deformations are very small
then
this implies that
[Music]
epsilon e is also expected to be
small which implies that epsilon
e square can be neglected
[Music]
in the previous expression therefore for
all intents and purposes
what we have is 1 plus
2 epsilon e is approximately equal to
1 plus 2
[Music]
n hat transpose strained dotted with
strain tensor dotted with this
so overall what we just obtained under
this
approximation is that this is so i am so
with a little bit of abuse of notation i
am writing this approximately as
equal to because we understand that we
are working overall under
small deformations so this is
just this
[Music]
okay now this expression that we have
obtained
it is an extremely important and
extremely useful expression
this one
you note it down very very carefully we
will see
that in
quite a different variety of problems as
well as for our theoretical developments
as well as for theoretical kind of
problems
uh this is uh very very important
and uh ultimately this is this is the
engineering stream
so let us try to interpret this a little
bit
before we end this part of the lecture
so
what is actually happening here so
suppose
uh so this is the physical
interpretation of this so
uh suppose we have uh a general
three-dimensional body let us go back to
that discussion
[Music]
okay and we are considering any general
point within it
fine now we can set up a certain
uh coordinate axis here no problem
let's say we have about this system of
coordinate axis
so x1 x2 x3
now refer to this coordinate axis we
will have
a certain displacement field under the
presence of some kind of loading in this
chapter we don't care about what loading
there is but we understand that there
will be some kind of mechanical loading
over this body
and under the uh under the effect of
that loading baseboard is going to
deform
this way that way whatever and some kind
of displacement field
is going to be established in it
displacement field means
just a description of how the
deformation has taken place
as it goes from this undeformed state to
some deformed state
that much we understand i am not going
to draw the deform state again here
so you understand that this itself is
the deformed state fine
all right now if this is the deformed
state
there is some value of u1 u2 u3
not at this point if you take another
point
there will be another value of u1 u2 u3
correspondingly so suppose instead of x1
x2 x3 you take
x y and z you will have different values
of uvw
so no matter what you what way you look
at it you will obtain different
different values of uvw
at different points all throughout the
body and all together
this is referred to as the displacement
field very easy to understand
okay now if you have this distribution
of displacement
okay displacement values so that that
entire thing is referred to as a field
so there will be
slight small small variations uh from
if you consider two neighboring points a
little bit of variation in u1
or u there'll be a little bit of
variation in v there'll be a little bit
of variation in w
uh along all the directions so if you
uh calculate the various derivatives you
will end up
with a certain value of the strain
tensor components here
so you let us go back to this previous
slide here
so you can very well calculate
the values of del u del y del v del x
all these things various values of this
okay i ask you
you i i mean i i provide you with the
information about the displacement field
you know the geometry and everything and
you can find out
the values of these derivatives of
course the understanding is that
i mean the mathematician will come and
say that okay
these these fields need to be
sufficiently smooth and all that but
okay for all intents and purposes as an
engineer you understand that
in usual circumstances this is going to
be smooth enough so you can find out
these
uh these derivatives and uh so all
fields are going to be differentiable
and
what have you so you can find out these
values
which means that all the strain
components that are present here the
epsilon 1 1 epsilon 2
7 3 3 the rest of them uh
equivalently epsilon x x epsilon y
websites that's it you can find out
fine so if you come back to this picture
basically
the picture that you have in your hand
is this you are sitting at this point
and at this point you you know the
various values of
of the string components fine which
means
that in this formula this entire formula
you know the various
the six independent components of the
epsilon
fine next what you do is
you ask the designer
or your customer maybe like in which
direction
you are interested in finding the
engineering string
okay so this is like a hypothetical
engineering question i am asking you
it's going to be far more complicated
than that but let's say
the person says that okay you tell me
the engineering string in that direction
that direction means a direction which
is
maybe at 45 degrees to the x-axis
at 60 degrees to the y-axis and some
angle to the z-axis
okay so in that particular direction i
want
my engineering string so all that you
have to do
is put the direction cosines of that
unit vector
here similarly here
do the entire multiplication how just by
going back to this formula
so here you see you know all these
values because you have already
calculated them
at that point and then as desired
you put the different values of the so
this n 1 n 2 and 3
are nothing but the direction cosines of
the desired direction
along which you want to find out the
engineering strain so you put down the
different values
and then you just have to do this entire
multiplication and
you will end up with a single value so
this is a second order tensor
this is a vector but ultimately when you
do finish the calculation you will end
up with a single value
and that single value is going to give
you the value of the engineering string
so what we say is that the engineering
string
is the strain along a particular
direction
given a certain displacement field in
the three-dimensional body
that is all there is to it so this is
how
uh and this is how the connection is
also established but what by
with what you have been studying earlier
so earlier what you are saying is that
like in your low first year classes or
maybe even earlier in your high school
that you are going to measure the
initial length and the final length
and then through a little calculation
you can find out the string
so all that is fine if you have a very
simple kind of
one dimensional body but in a general
three-dimensional body you have to take
care of the various directions
which is why we have to take all this
trouble to finally arrive at this nice
compact
uh notation okay so this is a very very
useful
very general very uh very much dependent
on the mathematical
framework but ultimately very useful for
engineering purposes
uh this formula all right so
we'll continue our discussion of
kinematics chapter in the in the next
part of the lecture
but uh as far as the strange section is
concerned
uh we are done with it there will be
some very interesting problems in the
problem sheets
uh in the problem sheet on this okay
thank you very much
you